let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
Madison cawthorne
with the hump dump
that's what he called it he said there's
going to be a massive dump
massive dump uh
a lot of people are pointing out the uh
the video
that dropped
that dumped on the internet
the hump dump the Madison Gotham video
we have an edited version for you here
on the Tony Michaels podcast that can be
aired on YouTube it is YouTube safe at
least I believe so you know I I don't
know I guess I guess only time will tell
if it is a YouTube State safe I believe
it is YouTube safe
and I don't know how you make this video
even more weird
but our executive producer and co-host
Gabe Sanchez made it even more strange
I have a lot of opinions about the uh
the video of Madison cawthorne but
here's the thing ultimately
this is really the rub
I mean
no no [ __ ] person that watched that
video that's like this is [ __ ] weird
probably
would vote for Madison Gotham in the
first place because he's a [ __ ]
insurrectionist he tried to overthrow
our constitution he tried to overturn
our government
so so most people I mean it stops there
like they don't need a video of him
teabagging his cousin because I truly
think that's what's happening in the
video and I'm gonna break down why what
I what I see in the video and tell you
folks in the audience what the [ __ ] is
actually going on in that video
because some people are saying maybe
he's having sex maybe he's you know
homosexual maybe he's incest
I don't believe it's any of that that's
right I don't think it's any of that
stuff
I'm gonna tell you why that video proves
that they think tanning their balls
makes them manly and they have to tan
their balls to make them manly
I'm gonna prove it to you here today
like I I look
I grew up around a bunch of Macho
machismo [ __ ] fragile white dudes in
White America
I know a lot of these [ __ ] you
know these all jacked up [ __ ]
think they're cool and bad
the only thing they can talk about their
accomplishments in life is the how many
touchdowns they had
in high school
anything past that you know
it's a rough story for them
I'm gonna I'm gonna show you and tell
you I'm gonna show you this video now
again we have to play the edited version
um us singers uh accounts got me rolling
this morning
um
because I was trying to think of what
the hell was in Madison cawthorne's ass
crack and uh they called it a butt
mullet
a butt Mohawk
um so we don't get to actually see that
in the video this morning
fortunately for you you don't have to
actually look at that but we will break
down what is actually happening in the
video because folks
what is happening in the video
is Maga culture
it's it's Maga culture it's white male
fragility
culture white privileged grievance
culture
this is this is why Tucker Carlson
continues on his show
this is why Matt Walsh Ben Shapiro talks
about women's vaginas as if they're
[ __ ] tough guys
they're very insecure about their
homosexual tendencies
and that's that's what the video shows
that's what the video shows they're not
I I don't think I don't think Madison
Gotham is gay and if even if he was I
wouldn't give a two flying [ __ ] if the
guy was gay or not I don't give a [ __ ] I
don't even care if he's gay and he hates
gays I don't give a [ __ ]
because I don't care what your [ __ ]
what your gender is who you want to love
who you want to [ __ ] I don't give two
[ __ ] shits I really don't
I could care [ __ ] less
I I don't really honestly I don't give a
[ __ ] I don't care if Madison Gotham
wants to have sex with women men and I
don't care about anyone else
but what is shown in the video is a
deep-rooted culture and even Madison
cawthorne when when he released his
statement about the video where his
cousin's touching his crotch in the car
he says something to the to the tune of
well if cell phones were around when you
were a kid he'd be [ __ ]
and he's talking to all the fragile
white males out there
all the ones that are homophobes all the
ones that are scared they're not manly
enough
they're all terrified
of their homosexual tendencies
now again I don't I don't think they're
actually gay
but these white fragile privileged males
walk around in this country
and they get to do whatever they want
they can put their balls on someone
else's face
literally that is what is happening in
the video
he can sexually assault his cousin
with someone filming
and no consequence no consequence I mean
other than you know releasing it on the
internet and denying denying that he's
having sex with his cousin just saying
oh well all I was doing was sexually
assaulting him that's all I was doing
come on now I was just teabagging him
for crying out loud what what white guy
in this country hasn't been tea bagged
before
that that's what he's saying folks
he's not talking to you
like he's not he's not trying to
convince my audience you guys out there
my listeners
that somehow this is some kind of locker
room [ __ ] he's not con he's not trying
to convince you
he's talking to all the other white
privileged white fragile grievanced
males out there
that are in the same situation
that there's probably video of someone
trying to teabag him or they've had that
experience
in a quote-unquote locker room
that is what is happening
that is what is happening in that video
and I'm gonna break it down and tell you
exactly what I think
minute for minute baby
President Biden says yesterday manga is
the
most dangerous political organization
ever in the history of our country
that's a bold statement I mean you
you're talking about the the Confederacy
and I call it the Cheeto dust
Confederacy you know here I call it the
Cheeto dust Confederacy
the shark army as it were Maga Q Anon
they're all one and the same
nincompoop Nazis like this is this is
them this is who they are this is what
they are this is
this is what they're gonna do
it's a q Anon World folks we're just
[ __ ] living in it
they're going to continue with this
nonsense this ninkaboop Nazi [ __ ]
they're not gonna quit
I mean the only question the only
question really that I posed this
morning is how many Madison cawthorns
are we gonna allow them to elect
it's us we are going to are we going to
allow them to elect more Madison gothans
to our Congress folks
because they're damn sure they're damn
sure gonna vote for Madison Gotham and
if you think Kevin McCarthy is going to
do anything about Madison caught their
own tea bag and his cousin on video
while who God knows who is filming the
son of a [ __ ]
I mean that's the craziest part about
the video
it's not like Madison Gotham set up the
camera someone's holding that camera
across the room
filming him tea bag his cousin do you
guys know what teabagging is do you know
what teabagging is I mean you can kind
of get the gist right
teabagging is where you put
a man
I can't even believe I have to [ __ ]
say this live on air I'm I'm serious
we're in a situation where I have to
describe what teabagging is to you guys
holy actual [ __ ] this this listen we
should not have to explain
what type of sexual assault is what when
it comes
two members of Congress
what would have happened
is when Madison cawthorne
was found out to be a fascist who wanted
to overthrow our government
who wanted to tear down our Constitution
and [ __ ] all over it
the people in his district should have
said no no you don't no sorry [ __ ]
don't get to do that Marjorie Taylor
green Lauren bobert Mo Brooks
uh gozar Andy Biggs the list goes on and
on and on here folks Josh Hawley Ted
Cruz all the ones that participated in
the Cheeto dust kangaroo coup to try to
overthrow our constitution to try to
topple our government
to try to nullify our vote
that should have been the straw like
that's when his constituency should have
said nope you're done [ __ ]
you think you think a little [ __ ]
video on the internet of Madison
cawthorne being exactly what they know
he is is gonna stop them from voting for
him
come on now
you don't believe that do you I don't
[ __ ] believe it I don't think this
video in any way shape or form loses man
and Madison got their own one goddamn
vote
we had a guy run for president
in 2016
on camera on a hot mic bragged about
sexual assaulting women
it's actually assaulting women
he said he'd grab him by the [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's what he said
on a hot mic
and at first they were like oh my God
this is horrible and then he was like
yeah it's just locker room talking like
oh okay well that makes sense we'll vote
for you anyways
and everyone's standing around wondering
how we got this [ __ ]
the
as U.S Singers This is the butt mohawk
someone accused me of
of uh making fun of a handicapper what
the [ __ ] does him being handicapped have
to do with what is going on in that
video someone asked to said that we were
making fun of a handicapped person what
the [ __ ] are you talking about
the first time I've ever heard that kind
of [ __ ]
and me handicap has nothing to do with
that video or what he's doing in that
video I mean I guess maybe the position
that he's in
because I think that's the confusion
here
the confusion about the video
about what's going on
Madison cawthorne happens to be
paralyzed and
to some degree he can't Jesus Christ he
can't teabag correctly I guess
most people out there probably don't
know what tea bag is never been tea bag
never considered
what teabagging is
but boy oh boy are we gonna know now
are we gonna know now oh [ __ ]
so we're gonna show the the edited
version the Gabe Sanchez edited version
and we posted on the uh Tony Michaels
podcast account last night speaking of
the Tony Michaels account uh podcast
account you can watch us live every
single Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central on Twitter on the
Tony Michaels podcast account just
follow at Tony Michaels pod and You're
Gonna Want to on Twitter and the reason
why you're going to want to follow us on
Twitter is because this afternoon in
this or sometime this evening we will
have the bonehead of the week Pole
and boy I boy I bet all hump dump is
gonna end up butt Mohawk is gonna end up
it's gonna end up on the bonehead of the
of the list or bonehead of the week list
so here's what happens when we do this
poll because we're also going to put it
on
on uh YouTube Gabe's gonna put it up on
YouTube
for you so you want to subscribe to the
YouTube channel we got a lot of new
listeners out there so if you're over on
Facebook just click on the link at the
top of the broadcast that'll get you to
the YouTube page or you can go to
Twitter and follow at Tony Michaels pod
and you will be able to vote for
bonehead of the week so here's what
happens with bone end of the week
we've been at a poll every single
Thursday every single week that's bone
end of the week there's three
contestants you guys get to vote you
decide who is the bonehead of the week
and then on Friday so tomorrow in the
second hour of the show because we do
two hours every single weekday Monday
through Friday
broadcast on YouTube Twitter twitch and
now from the Midas touch Facebook page
we simulcast to the Midas touch Facebook
page welcome to all of you on the books
of face
but we broadcast live and on Friday
during that second hour me and Gabe
break down your vote your vote we break
down your vote for bonehead of the week
and we go through not only the bonehead
of the week but dishonorable mention and
the alpha cook
boy this week should be interesting
and we're not even done folks we're not
done with this week yet we're not even
finished well Jesus
I want to welcome everybody here
um give me just a minute here welcome
welcome to everyone let's see holy moly
this list is long we got a long list of
live listeners today Chris n is here our
local hate Watcher thanks Chris for
coming Amanda's here dark dark Pepsi's
here uh Debbie from Salt Lake Kathy is
here uh Andrea's here Anita is here from
Facebook minus Margie is here for us
from Facebook Anita from Facebook
Kelly's here Nancy's here uh the 420 God
is here
holy moly um Tom from Facebook is here
uh don from Facebook is here Bobby Janet
from Facebook
let's see who else do we have here holy
moly we got a lot of new listeners this
is crazy we've been getting a lot of new
downloads we've been breaking records
folks all week long
all week long we've been breaking
records on YouTube and the downloads and
if you're not aware you can watch this
show live on video YouTube Twitter
twitch and the Midas touch Facebook page
because we simulcast over there
and you can also download each and every
single episode every single weekday
on Apple Spotify and Google and boy are
you guys downloading the holy living
[ __ ] out of this thing thank you very
much for you guys out there listening uh
participating in democracy
by listening to me yelling scream and
send the messaging through this
microphone
and not looking away we have to fight
for our democracy it's important inch by
inch yeah it's it's hard it's difficult
but we'll make it through we'll make it
through
uh the speaking of
speaking of heart and making it through
uh here's our co-host and executive
producer Gabe Gabe we're gonna we're
gonna go through an edited version
um that you created just so we can show
it on YouTube yeah um yeah I almost
think that your version
is a little more disturbing than the
original version it I mean to some
degree it's a little more hilarious if
you can find the hilarity in the
original video right right
um but I think a lot of people are
confused about this video and and I
don't know how you feel about it yet we
really haven't talked much about it uh
other than a few uh laughs in uh in a
chat you know over this over the video
that you had created right
um well not created but covered up I
censored I censored I'm sorry that I
censored the the Republican party on
this video I mean because clearly it was
the Republican Party who released this
video I just want to point that out
that's my that is my belief it has been
week after week after week of these
little little things not thing like it's
not little but big bigger stories I mean
it's a big like a big butt Mohawk kind
of right yeah exactly yeah a ferret or a
link or whatever you want to call what
was in between the the ass Sasquatch I
don't know there's a lot of things you
could call this thing the other thing we
Center it out because
you won't let us play it I don't think
yeah but I think it was last week you
were like oh there is the tapes and
there was the tweets and there was like
where's the video boom shakalaka Tony
Michaels is always on top of it I'm
always I'm always 12 steps ahead even of
the Q Anon crowd here I remember I
remember back when they were drinking
piss um you text me you're like great
days you're like hey I'm oh well we're
still kind of there but
um you were like hey I'm gonna make a
drinking piss video and I'm like nah
dude you gotta have him eating [ __ ]
they're that like like they're drinking
piss now like today if I release the
video that's old it's right right that's
all I'm not gonna be making fun I'm just
telling the truth right right you're
like I mean you're not doing parody
you're not doing Santa are you just I'm
just covering the news right
this is [ __ ] ridiculous
um that we even I even I have to explain
to the audience this morning what
teabagging is do you know what tea bag
do you know what team is where you put
it in the water right yeah that's where
you put a tea bag in the water exactly
I'm talking about the the the common uh
uh reference to a type of sexual assault
that you yeah the male uh yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's it's you know Madison gothorne
uh released some sort of video statement
and there's more vids about uh vids just
when you think they're
are there aren't enough there's more
vids there's more [ __ ] vids uh so the
vidgit that he released
um explaining the the last video because
the last video
um they were in the car it looked like
they were joking and and his cousin I
think it's his cousin yeah his cousin
his cousin who's the scheduler right
he's on his staff is what you're saying
Stephen Smith okay so so he's filming
with a camera and he kind of touches a
Madison goth order in scratch a lot of
people thought that he was that that
he's yeah I don't think Madison
cawthorne's gay I don't know really I
don't know and I don't know I mean
here's the thing I will say this there
were these I don't know if they were
verified but there were venmo exchanges
and I tried to look them up and they
might have been deleted they might have
been made private but uh there there was
a thread on Twitter of these of
basically a recounting of what happened
and then they had a screenshot of these
venmo transactions between Stephen his
cousin and Madison cawthorne and it was
very questionable and I'll see if I can
find it but it was very question on like
oh these might be alluding to something
more than just venmo payments right well
so that is a good point and I I want to
point out something here that that maybe
a lot of people don't know about white
male Macho machismo fragility
um you know homophobic type culture I I
just want to say the reason why they
were so supportive of Donald Trump even
after he said I grab women by the [ __ ]
you remember this
um the reason why they were so
supportive is because he called it
locker room talk right that's that that
was the that was the gist that he did
during the debate after it dropped he
went and and he was he was talking about
locker room duck now that is code word
to White America to white dudes in
America because white dudes in America
and I don't know if you've ever been
around this culture oh yeah I mean I
went to high school in uh in a suburb
and experiences firsthand so you so you
had said you had you had showers in your
gym is what you're saying yeah yeah open
showers in the gym I played on the
football team my freshman year I was on
the baseball team my freshman year like
so you definitely know what teabagging
is yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
luckily I was I was not the recipient of
that nor was I The Giver of that right
it was definitely not my thing they give
her or the receipt right yeah but it was
never my thing either it was never my
yeah definitely some some Bros that were
in the locker room and they're like
who's so funny and I'm like hey man no
judgment you do what you do right well
it for for folks out there who don't
know
um the reason why Tucker Carlson and Ben
Shapiro and Matt Walsh and Stephen
Crowder and uh Nick Fuentes all the
America first cat crowd Matt Getz
Madison gothorne the reason why all
these people are really uh deep-seated
homophobic
um Roots is it all Roots back from their
homophobic Tendencies when they're
teenagers and there's a lot of things
that happen in the locker room uh for
for for men and the reason why is
because there's some [ __ ] scumbags in
the locker room yeah and they've been
taught to be [ __ ] scumbags just like
you're taught to be a [ __ ] bigot or a
[ __ ] racist you you know you don't
you don't you don't born that way right
you were taught to be this way you're
taught this manly Macho machismo that
you have to you have to sexually assault
a man not a not just a woman you have to
sexually assault a man to show your
manhood to show your manliness your
Macho machismoism
um and a lot a lot of guys
well we'll do the whole extreme thing
where they teabag another guy yeah a lot
of guys will do the towel snapping or
the ass slapping or they'll you know
they'll do the they'll do the crotch hit
which is very proper they're goosing a
guy a guy goosing a guy is very popular
um in this culture
and this is what this video is I mean
maybe maybe Madison gothorne is is gay I
I don't know and I'm really again I
don't give and we don't care I don't
give a [ __ ] I don't think hypocrisy is
what we care about well not not just I
think not just the hypocrisy I believe I
believe that what is happening in what
is happening to uh to these white
fragile privileged
um men in this country is they do not
want to be exposed with these homosexual
tendencies and the reason why is because
they're terrified of it right they
believe they and and you can see it out
there on social media when this video
Hit everyone's like oh you're calling
him a home homo or you're calling him
gay or you're you're making fun of him
and this and that like back and forth
back and forth and and it all came from
the right well some of it from the left
but almost all of it's exclusively from
the right they were accusing people who
were posting this video right of making
a of gay jokes right they would use the
f word a lot yep
here's the thing
is that those folks that are sending
those comments are the same
[ __ ] that are terrified
terrified of that homosexual tendency
that that that would make them gay so
this Macho machismo culture where you
have to sexually assault another man to
prove your manliness you know outside of
tan in your balls right you've gotta
well I mean you know when you're in a
tea bag someone Gabe you want them to be
nice well yeah I mean you can't have
them looking ghost white pale like you
got you can't shock the person you know
you got to be like oh they're not so bad
you know right but this Macho machismo
white privileged
um and and really it is it is their fear
that they're becoming the minority and
they're gonna have their their privilege
stripped away from them and so it's the
grievance part of this
that's what this video is this is the
culture now in the video game and we're
going to show it here in a minute it
looks like
it looks like Madison cawthorne is
humping whoever it is because I'm not
really sure who it is it's hard to tell
who it is yeah
um it looks like he's humping him but
here here's my take on it Madison got
there and asked me no is handicapped he
he's in a wheelchair he does not have
the use of his legs and if you've ever
watched this type of sexual assault or
know anything about this type of sexual
assault
generally uh and I can't even believe we
have to [ __ ] say this type of [ __ ] on
air but you have to have the use of your
legs because you want to drop the tea
bag into the water as it were okay now
Madison caught there and as we know does
not have the use of his legs he is he is
he is handicapped right
we could go into a whole diatribe a why
and where and all that stuff and I mean
this is even this is something that's
even covered in uh the documentary
murder ball
if anyone's ever seen that that's no pun
intended right no right yeah well
it's it's uh it's a it's a documentary
about
um
full contact rugby in wheelchairs and
they're they cover the full spectrum of
like what life is like for being a
paraplegic or quadriplegic or whatever
it might be you know
um and how you kind of live life but
this is specifically that there's uh if
I remember correctly I saw it years ago
because it's like 2005 I think uh but
they even covered the topic of like what
is sex like right so so like when he
when he is doing this sexual assault act
because he's sexually assaulted rather
this person views it that way or he
believes in his lack room I mean it it
is a sector it is sexual assault no
matter how you look at it yeah I mean he
forced himself right on whoever the
other person is cousin or whoever that
was now because he was trying to teabag
this guy because that's in my view that
is what he's doing in the video because
there's another person filming it for
[ __ ] sake I don't know who the person
filming it is from across the room but
it's clearly someone filming it the
camera's moving around the phone's
moving around
um if you listen to the sound which I'm
not gonna play the sound because I don't
know if we'll get [ __ ] if we'll get
[ __ ] cut off for the sound and I have
no idea we put this up on YouTube has it
been taken down yet no I haven't even I
haven't made it public I put it as uh oh
Nick that son of a [ __ ] let's see let's
see what happens let's test the waters
here and see what the hell happens maybe
they'll cut the broadcast off folks I
don't know yeah I don't know the good
news is we're always on Twitch or
Twitter or might as much Facebook page
if we get off cut off from YouTube we'll
broadcast from there
um but here's here's the thing
is that in the video the reason why it
appears to me this is my view of it that
Madison gothorne is is quote unquote
humping uh the other the other person
apparently his cousin I think that's
what the the who the people are making
the assumption that it that it's the
same uh his same staffer and his cousin
that that took the video in the car
where he touches his crotch is that
right is that the assumption that yeah
the assumption is that's the same cousin
who's in the bed next to him that he
goes and right and himself right any
it looks like he's humping but to my to
what it what I view it as is he he's
teabagging him and because Madison
Gotham does not have the use of his legs
this is the way that Madison goth and
like you said there's things that you
have to do different when you don't have
the use of your legs I mean when people
are handicapped there's a there's a
reason why we have the 88 because they
have to have certain accommodations to
do things right and
oh my God I can't even believe I have to
say it's the accommodation for dropping
the tea bag in the water
um here would be that he would have to
do it a little differently than what is
uh normally done
um and how it's normally done so yeah
and and Jesus Christ this is this is
this is [ __ ] politics Gabe well yeah
unfortunately it is politics because
yeah okay yeah yeah let's just play the
clip and we'll talk about it after okay
I have something I have something to say
about the whole like High School
yeah Macho scene uh but I can say it
after okay let me let me pull up your
version here because we're gonna play
this censored version make sure that's
it okay we got the right version up here
okay this is
oh my God okay as you can see here on
the screen if you're watching or
watching
um you're gonna watch the video that you
possibly watch uncensored on probably
Twitter or something like that
um it appears that that uh someone has
placed Madison cawthorne's head or a
image of his head over his his butt
mullet or his butt Mohawk yeah um to
censor and also it's a little bit I
honestly didn't know that uh that you
could grow hair like that but well I
mean you know
maybe he should have it braided I don't
know I don't know I don't know this is
[ __ ] weird okay let's let's do the
whole politics tea bad thing here holy
[ __ ] uh this Harkens back to like the
tea party right yeah like this is the
Boston Tea Party this is the Madison tea
bag this is you know it wasn't taxes
that they were you know up in arms about
anyway okay let's go
[Music]
so you can see here he is crawling
um and he now he is
um well you just look at it I don't know
you [ __ ] look at it Jesus Christ and
if you're listening on the podcast
directories right now I don't know what
to tell you I'm not going to describe
what he's doing in this video if you if
you go you'll be able to find it it's on
our YouTube uh Channel now and it's
awesome the centered version we're not
going to share the yeah the privates now
you you can find you can find the actual
version that is people were very quick
to share it yesterday and I was like
yeah I'm not I'm not I'm not doing it no
I I didn't I didn't well I didn't want
it on my uh my Twitter page exactly and
I definitely I mean here's the thing on
the podcast there is uh you know there's
a ton of porn on Twitter okay right now
you can find
elon's gonna it make it even more
because it's free speech well yeah but
uh yeah this is this video free free
balling is that what you're saying yeah
yeah
free balling right to your structure you
pay for
um
this is it is certainly something else
like you know it's one of those things
where it's like oh you know there's like
rumors here's the thing when I
uh when I hear stories of like oh
there's a tape that was released like
the only tape I ever want to hear that
was released is the Trump pee-pee tape
okay
that's the one but but don't you think
don't you think that that Russia
probably has oh a hell of a lot worse
[ __ ] tapes than the people I mean I'm
not just talking about with like Trump
like maybe that's some of this [ __ ]
that's going on like I mean you you look
at this and you're like uh you know if
you can imagine what the GOP or or has
access to or has ownership of you know
to release photos and videos to then
just drop them in because Madison
cawthorne you know said some stuff he
wasn't supposed to say in a podcast and
then didn't apologize for it so then you
know the uh The Establishment that is
the GOP said well [ __ ] it we're going to
come after this guy and we're gonna get
access to these things and then they
drop it like little breadcrumbs a little
tape a little photo a little tape here
whatever and uh yeah so if this is what
they have on them I can only imagine
what the Russians have on the GOP and
especially Trump right right because
we've we've heard rumors of this uh
Russian hotel
uh
PP tape that was I I don't I just that's
the only way like you know that's the
only way I can call it listen I I don't
I don't want to Kink shame anyone no not
at all no no I don't if you want if you
want someone to piss on you well fine
whatever if it's consensual pee all you
want I have it have a urine Fest
whatever I really don't care if you
defecate on someone apparently we're
gonna talk about Amber Heard today I
guess she took the stand speaking of
defecating
um I guess she took a [ __ ] in Johnny
Depp's bed but hey whatever whatever
floats your [ __ ] boat I don't give a
[ __ ] as long as as long as it's
consensual it's not illegal yeah yeah
right it's that you know but did I
here's the thing did I imagine because
this this released yesterday afternoon
right and
did I imagine in all the things on my
bingo card that there was going to be a
tape of this that was going to release
no not at all I had no idea and I did
not anticipate that where my day was
gonna go right or that this morning we
have to talk uh
right yeah exactly on a show that's
supposed to be about [ __ ] social
issues and politics and I guess it is
associated because you said you wanted
to say some things about this High
School white male culture so yeah so
what I want to say about that is like
you know I definitely feel that within
the high school locker room the locker
room talk right you got one dude who
wants to be alpha or multiple man you
want to be the alpha and you gotta show
that I'm more of a man than you are by
doing something that you know I'm
assaulting another man I'm taking
advantage of another man I'm you know
whatever it might be they're very you
know there's a spectrum of things that
that guys do to other guys in the locker
room that is not okay right and it's a
damn good thing that we don't have it's
it that's the reason why we have boys
and girls locker rooms because it would
be a disaster if you but I think from
just the the psychology aspect of it
right there there is a huge component
that is is peer pressure right you are
someone between the ages of 13 and 18.
and you're in a locker room especially
if you're younger right and you just
want to fit in and you just want to do
the right thing so you're not the target
of that situation
uh you know very much though that's
that's what happens right you've got a
you've got a younger person who's you
know kind of impressionable and they
want to make sure that they don't become
the next Target and they want to they
want to stay on the team they want to
feel like I want to fit in I want to
make sure that I'm not that person that
it's going to happen to which is again
unfortunate that that is the situation
but it comes down to where the person's
like yeah get them get them you know do
whatever and they're just they're you
know they're kind of rallying the crowd
to make sure that they seem like they've
kind of assimilated into the group this
is what I [ __ ] by the way this is
what I [ __ ] hated about high school
sports that's oh yeah the reason why I I
actually I didn't play sports in high
school I did a little bit in Middle
School
um and that's that's kind of where it
started but I didn't play sports in high
school I was in gym class and that was
[ __ ] for one year for one hour a day
and that was [ __ ] enough for me I was
like I can tell you I mean I played
different sports uh in in my high school
specifically before I moved on to go uh
just row but um
uh yeah track baseball football
um you know just a medley of sports that
I was playing different years and each
time in the locker room there was always
that one guy right it wasn't that
specifically that same guy but it was
that one type of guy who was who was uh
kind of poking around and and seeing
what they could get away with and making
fun of people and instigating fights and
doing this and doing that because I mean
today they would be wearing a moga hat
right exactly 100 and those and that's
why like I look at the situation and
that we we're talking about right now
which is like you know this is something
that is brewing within you know high
schools depending on where you are in
cities or or suburbs or whatever but
it is that moment of like I'm an
impressionable vulnerable 13 to 18 year
old kid and it starts young because you
want to fit in
and just like you said you know it's not
you're not born with it you're taught it
well you're taught it in those
environments Rick points at a really
good point here Rick from Facebook says
racism works the same way and it does in
these locker rooms it's the same thing
and it's this Macho machismo male
um homophobic culture right that's
that's what Brews in this country and
it's taught it's a culture it's [ __ ]
gross it's the reason why we have a lot
of it's the reason why it's the reason
why
just this week we have [ __ ] people
cheering that women are going to lose
their [ __ ] Liberty exactly that is
the [ __ ] culture that is the culture
folks that is the and it's not manly
it's not Macho it's not cool it's
[ __ ] horse [ __ ] absolute horse [ __ ]
and it's been passed down generation to
generation from [ __ ] white dude to
[ __ ] white dude and you can hate on
me all you want you can hate on me all
you want but it's the white culture the
white privilege culture that has passed
it down and that that is where we're at
today and that's what we're seeing on
this video and Madison cawthorne in his
[ __ ] in his rebuttal or whatever this
video was that he released I don't know
if you watched it but he basically says
well if if anyone out there had a cell
phone uh you know 20 years ago you'd be
in the same position I'm in and that may
be true that may be true but what he's
saying is not about that it's not about
the [ __ ] cell phone yeah it's the
toxic [ __ ] white male culture is what
he's talking about that's what he's
saying now he doesn't know he's saying
that like he didn't he you know he he's
[ __ ] bone-in he couldn't even realize
that when he [ __ ] said oh yeah I'm
invited a bunch of cocaine field sex
orgies that he was telling on
Republicans because it's not a Democrat
wouldn't invite that man well also it's
like why would he associate himself with
other Democrats right like who's good
yeah one who's gonna invite him but two
why would he be mingling around with
Democrats when he so hates that side of
the aisle right it doesn't make any
sense so clearly the
you know if I were to play just like a
you know
just deducing what is left right it's
going to be uh
or like process of elimination the only
thing that's left is going to be
Republicans it's going to be the people
on the right side of the aisle and and
with this
you know him coming out and saying
um
oh hey this there's another hit coming
at me right right after the video
releases it's like okay one you could
have denied it like it's blurry one
could say that this isn't actually
Madison cawthorne and he could have
denied it and be like that's not me
that's a real whatever now obviously you
could fall very much into the same trap
that uh Kevin McCarthy fell into which
like you could do there's more tapes and
more stuff comes out or you could you
know kind of validate the authenticity
which is what he did
and I was like you know I don't know if
that's the best way to do it or you know
certainly the explanation I don't know
if that was the best way to explain what
was going on but certainly like
you know he said some stuff against uh
the GOP and the GOP has come after him
and now you know he's got you know
primaries in this month right well and I
I think that's that's the ultimate goal
here is to [ __ ] getting primary so
he's not he's not on the ticket but let
me let me um you know because it's it's
hard to wrap all this up in a bow
because I I can't even believe we have
to talk about
tea bagging this morning in reference to
politics for crying the [ __ ] out loud
but here's the thing is that our our
title for today is Maga hates America
and the reason why it uh is because Maga
is trending and
um the reason why Manga is trending
because Joe Biden called manga the the
most dangerous political organization in
our country's history
and Joe Biden is is even referring to
over the the Confederacy which I believe
that is what we have is a Cheeto dust
Confederacy I've said it over and over
and over I think that's what they want
to develop I think that's what the
tearing down a Roe v Wade is so they can
have their red States and you can have
your blue and we'll have a Cheeto dust
Confederacy like that's the attitude
here and that is what is happening in
that [ __ ] video Yeah in that video
the way that Republicans and fascists
are forcing themselves on us are
teabagging America
Madison caught throwing his teabagging
the the dude in the bed okay that is
what is happening that is the culture
and you they oh that you can't draw a
line bull [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't give a
[ __ ] if it's homosexual whatever I don't
even care
that it's hypocritical really because at
the end of the day the the reason why
they hate on the others is because they
fear they may become the others and what
the reason why they fear becoming the
others is this folks
this is the reason why because if we
want to oppress the others now what will
they do how will they oppress us when we
become the others that is their [ __ ]
attitude is we we love to oppress the
others what are they going to do when
we're the others they're going to
oppress us the way that we want to
oppress them they're terrified if they
don't take away women's Liberty women
will take power and take away men's
Liberty that is what they [ __ ]
believe and it's all all of this all of
this is the they're terrified of these
homosexual tendencies of these
they're just [ __ ] they're they're
nuts they're absolutely I mean at the
end of the day you know the people that
are that are cheering on fascism and
cheering on the removal of Rights like
you know from from from men to to women
to whoever they are right uh you know
they
are right now
not there there is no immunity there is
nothing that makes them immune
uh to any of this that they are cheering
on right because what ends up happening
is like again like I said yesterday you
know they're gonna look around and
realize that every like all these things
have been taken away from these groups
and then they're gonna be like wait wait
wait
I what hap I I thought I I thought I was
I thought it was one of the cool like
the good guys right I'm one of the cool
guys and they're like no dude you're not
rich you don't have any power you don't
have any uh influence you're just a pawn
you're right Cog in in the machine and
you have no say whatsoever you don't
think you like you're not who you
actually think you are right right
you're no one of value unless you're
actually providing me value and that's
from you know a capitalistic or or in
the polls or whatever it might be
crashes well I mean I mean I mean um I'm
gonna play a video here that
encapsulates our title today and really
describes what we're going through in
this country that they have convinced
these people to hate America to
literally hate America I mean
Gabe we have such a diverse country and
it's so beautiful that it's so diverse I
mean we we have we have white folks here
Brown folks here people of other
religions we have people from other
cultures for crying out loud the people
in uh in the South have a different
culture than the people in the in the in
the Northwest in the Northeast that is
the beautiful part about our [ __ ]
country is that we can live in a place
that assimilates to all these cultures
and such a such a vast array of
diversity like that is the beauty of it
like that is that is what get that is
our biggest asset is that we have such
diversity we have we have such
a multitude of culture
and and we we totally discount that
every single time and the reason why we
do is because they're terrified for some
reason that their culture is not going
to be valued like it is today the white
culture is the most valued culture in
the entire country and if you don't
[ __ ] believe me it's also the most
stolen culture I would say too well I
mean that that is that is what what
culture is right is they steal I mean
Elvis Presley is known as the king of
rock and roll well yeah yeah right yeah
no yeah he is yeah yeah yeah and the
reason why and the reason why he's the
reason why he's the king of rock and
roll is because he was the white dude
that would stand up and sing black music
that's why he's the king of rock and
roll he was the first real
talented artist to stand up as a white
man and do black music and sing black
music dance to black music and the
country [ __ ] loved it they [ __ ]
loved it and and that's just one example
here of how white people have
assimilated black culture and and other
cultures in general but that that is the
beauty of our country is that we have we
have such a diversity of people here and
and I and it it frustrates me
that people who claim to be Christian
who claim to be conservative that word
conservative do not want to conserve
other folks culture do you not want to
conserve our diversity they do not want
to conserve the fact that our country is
built on migrants
were built on migrant workers folks
oh by the way slavery they want to
Discount that fact they want to Discount
the facts and the reason why because it
doesn't suit them it doesn't it doesn't
suit this culture that is exhibited in
that video of Madison cawthorne it does
not suit that culture and that's what
pisses them off is it doesn't suit that
culture that's why that's why they're
[ __ ] oh you're you're shaming him
because he's handicapped you're shaming
him because he might be gay no we're not
I don't give two [ __ ] shits who
Madison cawthorne loves I don't give a
goddamn I don't really even care if he's
divorced or not and his marriage only
last eight months I think that's trivial
and stupid I think the guy who is a
fascist who wants to tear down our
constitution because he wants the
country to look more like him and to be
more like the culture that is exhibited
in that video because and and that's
what he is willing to tear down our
Constitution and our [ __ ] democracy
for that's what I have a [ __ ] problem
with yeah that's what I have a [ __ ]
problem with when he [ __ ] demonizes
people I'm not talking about the
hypocrisy I'm talking about him
demonizing people being racist being a
[ __ ] bigot and trying to trying to
push legislation through his party and
cheering legislation in his party to do
so they're not just talking about their
opinions they're [ __ ] trying to
legislate and change people's Liberty
turn it back now I want to play a video
here Gabe and I think this this this
video kind of inspired the title this
morning because me and you really were
trying to figure out what our title was
going to be this morning
I mean here's the thing the title the
title today is uh very much the title
for me every day every day every [ __ ]
day right some new story or something
that comes to light and you're like wow
this whole let's make this country great
[ __ ] right actually turns out to be
some [ __ ] grift or some facade or
some made-up idea just to make money off
the backs of other people and manipulate
them and put them into groups and then
say ah you actually don't get the rights
that with the Constitution says that you
get right right or the Amendments say
that you get or whatever it might be
like at the end of the day again
the group of people
right now
are trying to take your rights away and
it's the group that supposedly wants to
make America great so if you were to
take the two together
that's what they want that's how they
want to make it great take away your
[ __ ] rights and take away your
[ __ ] Liberty so let's watch this
video this is this video is back from
2021 I believe and then right and um
here's the thing uh that that the date
on the Tweet is 2021. but here's the
thing here's the thing about this this
video is there's one thing that this
person gets wrong in this video almost
everything is spot on right he calls
them he calls them conservative that's
what he calls them conservative and
they're not they're not they're not
conservative they're fascists but but
let's listen to this video this is a
fantastic video take a listen here
I'm always I'm always curious what
exactly conservatives mean when they say
they love America because you hate most
of the people who live here you hate the
civil liberties afforded by the
Constitution you hate the separation of
church and state you might claim to love
its economy but you hate all of the
states that make up the largest parts of
it you hate the government you hate
people who are anti-government you hate
the rich because you think they're part
of a conspiracy to [ __ ] your kids you
hate the poor because you think they're
lazy you hate this country's natural
beauty because it gets in the way of
Industry you hate industry because it
keeps giving jobs away to immigrants you
hate immigrants for taking things you
feel entitled to you hate liberals
because you feel like they're too
entitled you hate government
interference for getting in the way of
big business you hate big business for
being too globalized you hate globalism
for taking jobs away from American
workers you hate American workers for
unionizing and demanding better jobs
when you say you love America what
aspect of America are you actually
talking about
and that is why Manga hates America and
it is clear in this Madison gothorne
video that that culture and I know
people like Tony he's humping him how
does that have anything to do with
hating America I'm telling you it's that
[ __ ] culture
it's that culture that that has been
wrought on us and it's continuing to rot
on us from the minority by the way I
believe that there's I mean you Gabe do
you think more than 12 13 of people in
this country actually believe in that Q
Anon [ __ ] no I don't know really I
mean that on God's God's honest they
believe in it they're gonna you know go
to them they are they are the you know
the guru we're the silent majority no no
no no you you guys are a minority and
it's just like yesterday when we talked
about or we showed the clip of um
of Howard Stern right he was like it is
unfortunate that we sit and we we live
in a country where the minority can
speak for the majority right like we
look at how the decision was made on the
election right versus popular versus
electoral votes and you see that and you
say oh actually there's a minority of
people less than who voted for the
actual real winner right uh who could
decide what the outcome of the election
was and that's where we are right now
where is that's how we found ourselves
in 2016 which is you have Donald Trump
who loses by 3 million but actually he's
really the President right and so you
have a minority of people who are
actually made up uh making decisions for
the majority of people in the country
right well and I mean I think I think
that's
um going to have a hard backlash yeah
and the fact is is that I think that's
the divide and I talked about that
yesterday is the divide in our country
is not 50 50. divide in our country is
that people are [ __ ] sick and tired
of a few [ __ ] people telling everyone
else what the [ __ ] they should do and
not do like literally the party of get
your government out of my whatever it's
got their government all up in the
whatevers right everywhere [ __ ]
everywhere speaking of um government
getting up in the wherevers and there's
a graphic here that everyone's wanting
me to show this isn't a very good
transition but you know you know how it
is you know how it is here with those
sometimes it's smoothing sometimes yeah
well that well was speaking here's
here's a good transition speaking of
smooth speaking to smooth and hairy
asses
um here is Rudy Giuliani for some
comedic relief for everyone out there
he's running a new a newly printed book
I don't know if um Madison cawthorne
wrote the um
yeah that's a good question cousin
[ __ ] for dummies is what the book
says now you guys know the for dummy
series there you go for everyone in the
[ __ ] chat that wants to see this oh
boy I had not seen that photo you know
now you have to spread it around yeah I
was like I wonder who made that photo
was it was it Paul who did this who did
this uh it's not labeled it's not
labeled so gotta label that stuff steal
it steal it no I'm not gonna steal it
yeah because I've also got it the
internet Photoshop something and
someone's like [ __ ] internet I know
that's the whole point but also for me
as a as a designer and as an artist I
also would feel really bad if I stole
something and took credit for it you
know yeah what you know you know it's it
that's not to say that I couldn't find
this photo the original photo and I
could make my own book of you know like
a weekly thing of you want to write the
book is that what you're saying oh I'm
saying it no no no what I'm saying oh
okay what I'm saying all right like I
said earlier teach its own I'm not I
know look yeah no judgment but what I am
saying in the situation is that's not to
say that I couldn't find the original
Source photo of him reading whatever
that book is and then make a weekly
series called what's Rudy reading oh
that's perfect that's perfect well let's
yeah let's look for that Source photo
and see if we can
if someone has the source photo for this
Rudy photo this uh this reading please
send it I will uh I will I will work on
a series everyone is laughing here just
absolutely dying here over this photo
um so I guess I guess we should be glad
we glad we showed it here
um see we go from serious stuff yeah
well you know you gotta you gotta break
you gotta break this the ball sack and
not cathartic treatment therapy this is
[ __ ] man I don't know how many other
people out there but this is honestly
having another person to talk to and
reading the comments in the during the
show and after the show mean a ton
because one you guys like what we're
talking about but also like the fact
that you also have this moment of
cathartic kind of therapy to get this
[ __ ] out and be like this is a really
[ __ ] up timeline guys
most bizarre timeline
in history the simulation is broken
unplug unplug at home office unplug the
timeline and plug it back in would you
please but have you noticed in our chat
that that they don't just talk to us
they're talking to each other yeah and
that's great I know I noticed they help
each other in the chat they they cheer
each other on
um they help each other if they're
they're feeling bad that day we watch we
watch you guys talk we can't always say
everything that you guys say in the chat
if we did this show would be 12 hours
long
um and maybe it should be but we do
appreciate you guys coming here and and
and chatting and participating in the
show I want to thank uh Kalyn for
sending me the photo I really appreciate
that oh okay there you go so now it's in
the DM then okay I will I will work on
that as a weekly sign maybe we'll maybe
we'll work on what's Rudy reading answer
what what is Rudy reading that's a good
one that's a good one
um so back to what's trending uh now to
get away from this [ __ ] tea bagging
[ __ ] for crying out loud
um we have Kyle Rittenhouse uh Joy Behar
I'm not sure exactly why she's trending
uh uh well it was it may be comments on
The View right I I well I think there's
I think she said something on The View
but I couldn't find a clip you know on
here yeah yeah I don't I don't know
about the clip but I did was it this
morning that she said this or was it
yesterday oh I don't know I saw well I
saw yesterday like Whoopi was trending
on The View because they made comments
about Roe versus Wade but I don't know I
got you there was something specific of
that Joy Bayer said I don't know I see I
see what well also look also vote
conservative is trending Al franken's
trending uh Amber Heard is a liar that
hashtag is turning 12 000 mules is
trending I think that's the stupid
[ __ ] the film that they showed at
Mar-A-Lago that's why Kyle Rittenhouse
is trending because he was standing next
to to Laura Logan and he couldn't help
but uh feel
whoo you got to see the photo I'll show
you the photo yeah it is something else
yeah he is
um that [ __ ] [ __ ] box uh Karl Marx is
um is trending
um of course it's Cinco de Mayo hey
uh I I know I know you are a a taco and
burrito connoisseur it's in your it's in
your bio yeah it is it's like a title I
love I my I love Mexican food but what
what we should do
we should change your title from co-host
and executive producer to local Taco and
burrito kind of Sword I mean if we want
to make a segment where it's just me
we're viewing Tacos on the show oh I
yeah sure if you want to make taco damn
I'll do that let's do it I think people
would love that I think the audience
would love to watch you eat tacos and
drink your soda stream water whatever it
is that yeah well here's the thing if
I'm eating the tacos I probably wouldn't
be having SodaStream like bubbly water
what I would probably be having is like
a Mexican Coke or I'd be having uh maybe
a beer you know something to go with it
maybe a little line in either one of
those so something carbonated just yeah
something carbonated but a different
flavor than just like water you know
that's not to say that I don't eat tacos
with carbonated like bubbly water but do
you ever do you ever make your own tacos
or do you always do all the time out
yeah I've got a I've got a tortilla
press uh here in the kitchen uh you got
all kinds of kitchen appliances yeah I
mean that's probably like most of the
only thing that I'll ever make is like
tortillas but tortillas are great and
they're also like a super cheap very
easy snack right like you make the
tortilla you heat it up you put a little
salt on it roll it up maybe you put a
little lime on it uh and it's like a
nice little snack it's also like you
know have a little tortilla soup with it
oh my God see you're making me [ __ ]
hungry we're yeah the first hour here I
haven't even had a breakfast yet and I'm
already thinking because I know I'm
gonna have tacos later today this is
ridiculous but
for anyone who can go get a meal go get
yourself a taco or you know whatever you
want to eat take take the podcast put it
in your your air pods or your headphones
Taco talk with Gabe Sanchez yeah hey I'm
down for it if you want to do some taco
reviews uh get the taco reviews going
we'll play them on the show
um we're gonna come back here right
after this we're gonna do we're gonna
surf the Tweety tweets and Eternity
Trends um in proper form so stay right
here don't go anywhere we will be right
back to surf the Tweety tweets and the
trendy Trends stay right here I'm gonna
go grab some lunch
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[Music]
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
it looks like our video is staying up on
YouTube
so the uh the edit and the blur and the
censorship the cancel culture
Gabe canceled Madison cawthorne's butt
butt butt Mohawk sorry it's working that
that's probably the conservative
censorship that they're complaining
about I guess so yeah that you're
censoring him am I being censored you
know it's like is my butt mullet being
censored his his Sasquatch ass I don't
know what the hell that is but it's
censored go look at it on YouTube don't
forget to subscribe on YouTube this is
very important folks Gabe have you
noticed we have had a record amount of
new Watchers this is yeah this is great
Bonkers I want to say hello and thank
you to all the people that are uh
that are watching that are subscribed uh
that's right that really appreciate it
not only have they subscribed to YouTube
they they're downloading on on all the
directories Spotify Google Apple so guys
go go download you can download every
episode and I don't know if you notice
this but we just started this last week
we're gonna do something special where
we actually drop
not a Madison cawthorne kind of drop not
that kind of drop not that kind of dump
we're not doing hump dumps it's a hit
job baby right right we're gonna drop a
best of episode every Saturday so we
take the clips from that week so the
best of the week we take clips from that
week and we put them in one episode and
we'll put it on YouTube Twitter twitch
and the minus touch Facebook page we
also are putting that in the podcast
directories where you can download the
audio Yeah the other thing that we do
because Gabe tomorrow do you know
tomorrow's Friday tomorrow is Friday
tomorrow's Friday do you know what we do
on Friday in the second hour in the show
bonehead of the week bone end of the
week is tomorrow in the second hour
someone teabag him please okay uh so we
we are gonna do bone end of the week but
here's the thing Gabe they have to go
over to Twitter and follow at Tony
Michael's pod they can also subscribe on
YouTube and see the poll there that is
true our audience convinced you that you
definitely need to put the poll on you I
will add the poll on YouTube you know
I'm sure you know what's next Gabe you
know it's like they're gonna want this
[ __ ] on Facebook we're gonna have to go
to I don't think you can do well I don't
think you could do polls on Facebook
right you can't I don't I I don't know I
don't know does anyone out there on the
books of face no I'm not on yeah but you
might have to do it it would have to be
through like the Midas touch right so
we'd have to go to the suit status yeah
we'd have to ask them and say Please do
this right we we really have to work
hard so the mizellis brothers out there
if you're if you're bone into the weak
band and you want to vote on Facebook uh
you might you might you might start
tagging them I don't know maybe leave
some comments and say that you like this
video
but here's the thing if you go to the
YouTube channel And subscribe and you go
to the Twitter account at Tony Michaels
pod you will find the poll there every
single Thursday now sometimes it's later
in the afternoon sometimes it's an
evening because we're kind of trying to
let these boneheads develop right
they're just bubbling up oh my God
because they get [ __ ] boneheads
everywhere I mean I could I could I mean
you know I've got a list of people so
far but at any moment someone could do
something that is more bone-headed right
say oh you know what now I'm I'm now
this person's in the top three right and
we have to figure out who's going to be
the alpha cook and who's going to be the
dishonorable mention right well you know
what you know what's funny about bone
end of the week like we'll put out the
poll and we're like oh surely this
person's gonna win and sometimes they do
and sometimes they don't but by the time
the morning rolls around we're like ow
[ __ ] we should have put this person on
the bone end of the week like God damn
and then we got like five of them that
we're trying to choose from for the
extra two slots that we have we have
made so that we can slide in yeah
these are these are honestly these are
game time decisions that are being done
right right before the show right like
if you if you um
you definitely want to shave your butt
crack for this kind of race yeah
definitely and you want to be you know
yeah I mean you know sometimes and
sometimes it's razor thin you know right
right yeah you know
oh my God I cannot believe
this is politics this is politics 2022.
man this is the unfortunate reality we
live in we're now
you know we can't we can't talk about
the privacy of your own home or hotel
room or whatever it is has to you know
if you say something against a party
that they don't like especially the GOP
then they're going to surface that stuff
up and just you know try to try to get
you out of your your position absolutely
crazy mind is Robin thank you for the
Super Chat she says thank you for having
our backs much love and respect Midas
mighty
and we we love the minus Mighty here did
you know we also have sparklers how
sparks fans are called sparklers we have
sparklers
yeah yeah so we got the [ __ ] em fam we
got the minus Mighty we got sparklers
here I don't know it sounds like an
Avengers type crew yeah it is I think
that's hey that's not a bad idea yeah
we're the Democracy Avengers right you
got the three myself Brothers you and me
Hal like you know which which who are
you are you Ant-Man in that scenario or
yeah I'll be in man is that I mean you
know if you had to pick one that might
be a good one to pick I'd say like that
or like you know you're like a
Spider-Man you know I don't know I'm a
neighbor you know your friendly
neighborhood spider all right well I
might I might want to be
um Thor you know because he's a guy he's
a guy well maybe maybe though maybe
though maybe though the Hulk wouldn't be
too bad either and I'm talking I'm
talking about original Hulk like yeah
not like smart not smart Hulk no no no
I'm I'm not the smart Hulk for crying
out loud let's not go hour thank you
thank you Robin for the uh this the
Super Chat uh everybody here we go we're
we're gonna get to the issues here
because we are we are nine minutes into
the second hour we have not served a
single Tweety tweet or trendy Trend so
let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
we are at the point of the shitless
Roundup for an hour and 10 minutes in
but we finally got here Gabe um I want I
want you to tell us about your
experience of Cinco de Mayo
um you know I am my own experience but I
know you probably as as a kid you
probably celebrated Cinco de Mayo a
little differently than some other folks
in the country tell us tell us what
Cinco De Mayo means and uh tell us the
kind of Celebration that it was when you
were a kid yeah yeah so well I mean
Cinco de Mayo it's not the independence
uh people think that right uh it's
actually a celebration
um that commemorates the anniversary of
Mexico's victory over the French Empire
uh in uh
eight eighteen sixty two okay uh here I
can look that up if someone wants to
double check but I believe it's 1862.
um the Battle of Pueblo so that's the
the quick and dirty of it uh the way
that it's celebrated obviously in
America is that people are
um
uh
drinking right eating a course whatever
yeah hell yeah right that's the way it's
the same person the same way that people
uh celebrate St Patrick's Day right
um or fourth of July or Christmas Easter
it's just an excuse right like yes it
gets people together and that's cool but
uh it's just an excuse to uh
yeah drink get drunk it's right yeah
yeah it is America yeah and a lot of
people and yes a lot of people do
believe like oh Cinco de Mayo Mexico's
independence is like nope that's nope
that's not that that that's months uh
months apart from this date now from
what I understand that's like one of the
the one of the days that like the most
tequila is sold
um in this country obviously because I
wouldn't doubt it I'm sure I mean you've
got tons of deals people I'm I guarantee
that people are gonna be like oh come to
this restaurant we got you know Cinco de
Mayo specials and we've got margaritas
and we got tequila we got this and we
got this all this stuff so yeah I
wouldn't be surprised that uh as as
Cinco de Mayo is the
de facto you know Tequila uh drinking
day in this country so did your dad ever
tell you like uh in Mexico did they
celebrate it different there then like
was it yeah yeah yeah yeah and so it's
celebrated differently everyone it's
still a celebration I mean like right
like a lot of things that we do in
Mexico it's just like a lot of family
you know there's a lot of family and
their culture and traditions
um that we do in different ways it's not
as big as it's made out to be in in
America right uh like you wouldn't go to
places in Mexico and you wouldn't find
all these people like oh we're doing
it's Cinco de Mayo so we're doing these
and this and this is like it's not that
big of a deal it's still something that
is important but it's not like crazy big
where it's like you're going down the
street and you're seeing uh bar after
bar after bar after bar restaurant after
restaurant that says
um
come in for a shot coming for this
coming for this celebration right
um you know but yes like they're you
know there are many Traditions that we
have in Mexico and my dad I mean
obviously as my dad who owned uh you
know he is a he is a chef and uh and
owns restaurants you know yeah that's
where the love of tacos comes from well
also it's the love of tacos come from
just the fact of like hey uh I'm making
a meal like you know Saturday mornings
would be like
um
um chorizo and eggs and uh and what else
we do uh we and we make little tacos out
of them you know like it was a very it's
also a very quick meal to make as well
right and you're like oh I'm gonna put
scrambled eggs
and with some chorizo and I'm gonna put
it in a little corn or flour tortilla
whatever you want
put a little cilantro maybe some
radishes boom done yeah um yeah
now this has a video here they say uh I
found this video I I haven't watched it
yet but we're gonna watch it here if
you're going going to celebrate Cinco de
Mayo you should know or at least know
what it is
um so let's let's see if you can
um let's play this here see what they
say before you put on that sombrero and
fake mustache for Cinco de drinko make
sure you know what you're actually
celebrating for one it's not actually
Mexico Independence Day that is
celebrated on September 16th and if you
want to party with us you're more than
welcome to but again leave the sombrero
at home May 5th is actually the day to
commemorate Mexico's victory over the
French in the 1862. God damn about 1862.
most of which were agricultural workers
not even trained to hold a rifle went up
against what was considered to be the
greatest military force in the world
France outnumbered them by at least 2
000 soldiers yes Mexico still won today
in Puebla on Mayfair there's usually a
military parade and once that's over
people celebrate in the Square to eat
Mexican food and listen to Mariachi so
in Mexico they do celebrate Cinco de
Mayo but not at the scale in which we do
in the U.S so when exactly did Cinco de
well [ __ ] you already said all this I
know I'm sorry
well you know you know what's um what's
interesting about this is the part where
um they celebrate with food you know
like yeah
um because Americans do the same thing
but we do it like we do the like he was
saying Cinco de drinko like we do the
food and alcohol together like if you're
gonna have a meal oh you gotta get drunk
too right right that's the that's the
thing so maybe that's where it comes
from in this country and it's called
capitalism yeah yeah let's finish the
video become another St Patrick's Day or
Oktoberfest in the US yeah
when alcohol companies tried tapping
into Latino Market by promoting a day
that was already celebratory in nature
we go with the capitalism in California
it's not all negative with cinco de mayo
though the holiday has actually eat some
positive recognition from the US
government Cinco de Mayo received its
own commemorative postage stamp in 1998
and it's also observed at the White
House though this isn't the right way to
observe it
that's not authentically I forgot about
that photo until right now for all for
all of you out there listening and not
watching uh the photo that popped up on
the screen there is when Donald Trump I
believe it was in 2016 when he was
running for president he was sitting at
his desk in his office at Trump Tower he
had ordered uh a taco salad bowl I
believe yeah it's one of those it's one
of that [ __ ] whitewashed taco bowls
it's salads where it's like white people
tacos it's like chopped uh iceberg
lettuce and it's in a huge bowl that has
been molded that's just fried and then
you supposed to eat it at the end it's
not good
now easy they can be good Gabe I haven't
had one yet that has been good because
here's the thing it's the way that it's
layered is you have beans and the bottom
then you have your meat then you have
whatever toppings lettuce you know
cheese whatever's on there so at the
bottom it's just soggy the outside is is
hard and crisp and then the bottom is
soggy the thing falls apart it's
terrible and the ingredients it's like
just give me I would rather just have
tortillas on the side and have it in a
bowl itself let's not try to let's not
try to make this [ __ ] into something
that it isn't did you guys notice out
there listening that Gabe he totally
jumped over the over avert racism that
Donald Trump had with his thumbs up with
the taco bowl and he's like [ __ ] that
taco bowl I mean he is Raging Raging
about the taco bowl the hell I mean yes
that photo is [ __ ] racist here's the
thing isn't there also a photo of him on
the plane doing the same thing or was
that no no that was with the fried
chicken is that what it is I don't I
don't know what was that what was the
Fried Chicken thing that he did I don't
want to say what it was yeah okay look
it up we'll we'll finish watching this
video here and while you're looking that
up Mexican Cuisine under the Trump
Administration Mexican Americans and
other Latino communities feel like
they're under attack so
it's so important this year to be
culturally sensitive as America is a
Melting Pot of different cultures we
need to remember not to only Embrace
Mexican Traditions but Mexicans
themselves I'm Mexican-American and I
choose to ignore people sometimes
culturally offensive behavior on this
day but I personally would never
discourage anyone from consuming tequila
or enjoying Mexican food because it's
the best just try to be informed while
doing it what I do discourage is
ignorance and cultural appropriation so
go ahead and enjoy the margarita and
taco deals but skip out on the tacky
mustache and obnoxious and if you truly
want to honor Mexico's Heritage try
looking for a Cinco de Mayo celebration
hosted by a local cultural organization
in your city now someone gave me a
tequila shot before I go back online and
see people wishing me a happy Mexican
Independence Day gracias yeah
so so they that Mexican
um Independence Day was trending earlier
probably the reason why is because
people were debating then I would
imagine there was one or the other but
um um so I learned a lot in this video
um well mainly I learned from you and
then watched the video and it was
confirmed in this now on now this video
so yeah so thanks for giving us uh the
lowdown before we got the lowdown and
again it is a it is obviously it's a
great holiday it's an important holiday
and like I said like a lot of our stuff
is surrounded by food and family right
like it's just culture and tradition and
like when I go you mean you're humans
come on come on we're not all bad people
oh okay Tony we're not all but just like
they're not all oh my God here we go
don't even say it don't even say it I'm
not even gonna go there but what I will
say about it is uh yeah like the how
many how much of our day and it's great
how much of our day at least without my
family is surrounded by food is because
you know food food and that culture
brings everyone together right you're
around the table you have breakfast you
might have like a brunch you you know
kind of style there's you know then you
might have uh you know there's supper
and dinner kind of like how that's laid
out and they're it's just like multiple
meals throughout the day where you're
just going over to someone's house
having a meal hanging out leaving coming
back at another time to have another
portioned meal
you know and it could be something as
small as just like you know tortilla
soup or it could be a whole big thing
right right
um but it's just the aspect of bringing
people together you know um speaking of
that you know we have this thing here in
the country and there's a lot of
different types of you know what what
people want to call authentic Mexican
restaurants or Tex-Mex you know there's
a lot of different versions of the
American Mexican restaurant right um and
and they probably you know I I correct
me if I'm wrong but most of them are
American Mexican restaurants they're not
exactly yeah um you know authentic
Mexican I would say but but here's the
thing is that
um like in some of these small towns
like there are Mexican authentic Mexican
restaurants
and like they're the family restaurants
which is crazy that these people who
would wear manga hats and you know chant
build a wall
um would go in and enjoy the the culture
and assimilate the culture like he was
saying by wearing the sombrero and
acting like you know boneheads
um and not just not just knowing what
the true history is like what it
actually means why you're going and
drinking The margaritas right why you're
going and eating the Mexican food at
your local small town authentic Mexican
restaurant I mean and and they don't
even get it and really honestly
um it's I hate to say it but it's the
same culture that is in that [ __ ]
video of Madison gothorne and yeah and
it's in the video of when his cousin
touches him on the crotch it's the same
thing it's the exact same thing it's
just two different kind of extremes here
and speaking of that
um Gabe Madison Gotham speaking in the
attorney generals and Tweety tweets um
what did he do I I don't know if there's
um uh CNN is reporting an opposition
group that is actively can campaigning
against Madison Gotham has released a
video clip appearing to show the North
Carolina Republican naked in bed and as
Catherine describes it being crashed
with a friend acting foolish
um so they're reporting now and he's
trending it looks like but that was
seven hours ago yeah is there something
later go to let me see if there's go to
latest
uh latest well that's gonna have a lot
of tweets let's see yeah I mean if
you've done some articles in there
yeah
but while you're looking at that I want
to let everyone know that Trump as of
today uh by the end of today will owe
um 100
000
in fines because he's being held held in
civil uh contempt okay I gotta pull this
off while I'm going through the
MacArthur and thread I guess the videos
the videos
but yeah as of uh as of by the end of
today it'll be a hundred thousand
dollars because Trump is refusing
to uh share the documents that he says
now no longer exist and I think as of
yesterday uh Tuesday Tuesday or
Wednesday
um and this is specifically with the
civil case civil rights with the New
York attorney general yeah okay and uh
they tried to appeal it again and a
judge said no
so this is the second time I believe
that he has been uh denied or rejected
his appeal from a judge so so that
that's that's breaking news right now
that was uh as of yesterday it was an
update but I'm telling you right now
that the amount is up to a hundred
thousand dollars I gotcha I get you
because he's been denied he's been shut
down twice and it just only keeps adding
up
I was surprised by that that it wasn't
trending all morning that it's just now
it's just now hitting the charts at
number 11 I feel like Casey Kasem
cutthorne the butt mullet video is comes
in at number 11 on the on the top 30
charts and it's really [ __ ] weird by
the end of the day will you see him come
in the top ten well that's okay easy
easy Gabe easy [ __ ] band You're Gonna
Get Us [ __ ] band just by just by
being puns I I didn't mean to say that
it just yeah well it just come out I
came out yeah yeah
um you can see number 14 here's where I
was talking about earlier Mexican
Independence Day is trending um because
people are probably arguing in that
thread whether it is Mexican
independency or not uh manga is trending
at number 15. the reason why Manga is
trending at number 15 is because uh Joe
Biden the vice president of the United
States said that Maga is the most
dangerous political organization in our
country's history
right wing is freaking the [ __ ] out I
mean they're going crazy I mean well you
gotta quickly scanned over that one no
no that's all oh that's ours okay okay
see the nice the nice bonehead
see how Gabe yeah there you go that's
good there you go yeah that maybe this
should be look at that there's 250 000
views already yeah the audience uh yeah
we were when when I when I sent it to
you and then you're like yeah let's put
it up I was like all right cool and I
didn't think anything was really happen
with it within like 10 minutes it was
like 5 000 views and I was like this
thing is well everyone wanted a censored
version they didn't want to see his hair
right yeah I will say yeah no one wanted
to see the the butt Mohawk they're uh
there obviously was a market for a
censored version of the uh Madison
cawthorne teabagging porn or whatever
the [ __ ] it is I don't know why you
would describe it as
um I do you think do you think that this
is gonna cost him votes I don't think it
is what what he said or what he did no
what he did I don't think he's good I
mean the people who voted for him they
voted yeah because of the like they're
gonna be like ah well you know he he
likes to fascist policies you know it's
the whole bus Grabber thing I I think
that in the time between now and
whenever the the primary is you know I'm
sure what they're probably gonna have
debates right I hope he wins I hope he
wins the primary that's what I'm hoping
but yeah I don't know I mean like here's
there's there's a part in my mind where
I'm like either he becomes so anti-gop
establishment he goes left right because
there is that come on no no no I don't
think he will but this guy with the
[ __ ] with it I don't think he will I
don't think he will but what I am saying
is like when you go anti-gop
establishment like where where else is
there to go right do you go more to the
center
right can you move a wave the group that
you were you were fat you were like
buddy fascists with right you're like
friends with fascism right like if you
had that and they're now throwing you
under the bus do you go further right I
don't know which side of the crack the
hairy crack you're on I don't know
that's a good sign that's a good
question
the left or right I don't know what does
it mean
ah and whether you shave it or not
before you decide which side you're on
uh Christopher here points out uh
Madison got throwing acting righteous as
hell
um this wasn't that long ago how many of
his Republican colleagues heard this and
knew the truth as they watched him tear
down the lgbtq community to score points
with the manga Christian Base
um this is Madison Gotham here in a
different video on the floor of the
house where he's giving a speech on
April 4th and so this is not that long
ago just just over a month ago April 4th
2022. let's listen to what Madison goth
and what Christopher's pointing out here
speaker
the left has ripped away the pin of
truth from the author of life
they've exchanged Natural Science for a
party platform and declared war on
biology
your left wing movement is forcing
children's to endure radical expressions
of sexuality and yet you can't even
Define what a woman is
radical forms of sexuality you mean like
you mean like never mind never mind he
talked about the he said the Democrats
were party people right right you know
this this this video here should [ __ ]
piss more people off than the [ __ ]
video that's circulating around the
internet last night let's let's finish
playing you might have been to Bill but
you'll never amend biology
science is not Burger King you can't
just have it your way oh Jesus I am the
youngest member of the House of
Representatives
we all know Mr Burger King have it your
way that you're the youngest literally
his references his references you is is
the duty tea bag writing this speech
yeah like well the other thing too is
this guy is what 26 right now and every
tweet that he has he's always like oh
when I was younger and everyone's like
dude you're 26 man when I was younger
what do you mean it was like two years
ago right right six months ago I mean
everyone's always younger right I mean
you're always like yesterday I was
younger than I am today so you know I
learned a lot oh Jesus let's let's
listen to his bigotry because that's
coming I know that's coming full press
here I can already sense it imagine that
one of my sacred duties in this hollow
chamber would be explaining to the house
Speaker the difference between a man and
a woman take notes Madam speaker I'm
about to Define what a woman is for you
XX chromosomes no tally whacker it's so
simple
and yet today this proclamation of
fundamental fundamental scientific fact
will cause the woke liberals in Silicon
Valley to strip you of your voice and
ban you until you bow at their altar
falsehoods so so what they want to do is
Ban the people who want a tally whacker
or don't wanna I don't know what the
[ __ ] he's trying to say also it's not
Silicone Valley it's Silicon Valley well
I mean depending on depending on if
you're putting it in a tub or not right
you know if you're gonna make sure your
tub is nice and you know water tight it
might be silicone I thought you would
caulk it well you might you might tally
whacker it you might tell I don't know I
have no idea you've got a [ __ ] it you
gotta stick your cup all right all right
all right
let's listen to the rest of this bigoted
this is a Gabe the thing that people
don't understand is the video that you
censored is not in official record right
that's not a fish record yeah what this
[ __ ] fascist is saying is an hour
official record
our official record the [ __ ] he's saying
here is ours forever and we get to look
the history will look back on this
official record and be ashamed of what
this [ __ ] is saying about other
human beings because he's being censored
because he wants to [ __ ] get rid of
the others
Patriots like Charlie Kirk and Tucker
Carlson yeah have been muzzled on
Twitter for promoting the dangerous and
figurative ideology called science yeah
yeah it is it it is bigoted anti-science
[ __ ] rhetoric is what it is but also
Charlie Kirk can't tell the difference
between the fetus that's a baby right a
dolphin right and and Ben Shapiro and
Tucker Carlson apparently can't and and
this is just it's getting we're we're
making a computer Ben Shapiro just
yesterday I believe it was is going out
and saying how he actually wants them to
repeal the same-sex marriage that was
that was approved by the Supreme Court
right people are like oh it's not going
to happen it's like you've got this
[ __ ] saying it out loud right
and you've got other Representatives on
the state level who are saying it it's
going to be pushed in that direction and
hey do you allow this to be overturned
hey dudes out there with Tally whackers
you manly men they're gonna they're
gonna come after your contraception too
like this isn't they're gonna come after
make it illegal for you to have
contraception it's gonna happen they're
not gonna [ __ ] stop they won't stop
so when you have an unplanned pregnancy
what the [ __ ] are you gonna do now
because you couldn't prevent it even
with contraception right there or
without contraception [ __ ] boneheads
Madam speaker you and your party are
living a lie The Babylon bee is a more
reliable source of fact than you oh
Jesus Christ when you hand the gavel to
Republicans and realize that truth is
King it reigns with the American speaker
and you madam speaker never will again
okay there's the big it kind of sounds
like a threat but whatever he hates he
hates he hates being canceled because he
wants to cancel other people he should
be able to cancel other people without
consequence God damn it he should be
able to ostracize people from society
call them names
and hate on them
without consequence get the [ __ ] out of
here with this [ __ ] okay so that's the
that's the manga Trend
um let's go back here let's see what
else is uh in the trendy Trends here
because conthorne's trending uh
DuckTales is trending Gabe did you watch
DuckTales the show I get I don't know
DuckTales uh didn't they they came back
with it because what is your top top
five cartoon theme song oh that's why I
thought they did on Netflix or something
they came back with DuckTales and like
Danny pootie who is a voice of one of
the characters I believe okay
um but yeah isn't that set or is it is
is it or is it Darkwing Duck that Seth
Rogen's doing
I believe it's Darkwing Duck
oh you people out there
um uh breaking the NASDAQ uh composite
plunge is five percent drop nearing four
percent so we're having a drop in the
NASDAQ today oh that'll be fun that'll
be fun to explain to people how the
market fluctuates uh let's see oh to
confirm what you said yes it is Seth
Rogen and he was working on a Darkwing
Duck reboot okay I gotcha so that so
it's not still working for it's still
it's for Disney plus but it's still uh
and it works right so Darkwing Duck is
kind of a spin-off from DuckTales
um if anyone out there doesn't know okay
of course folks my age no
um if anyone wants to go back down the
Nostalgia rabbit hole with us please
right right uh Chris Chris Smalls
Christian Smalls as he's known as well
um for the Amazon labor unit is
apparently appearing before the Senate
budget committee right now
um so once we're done with the show go
check out
um the C-SPAN video of Christian Smalls
did you guys you guys seen I played this
video of um Christian Smalls on Tucker
Carlson did you you remember watching
that video game where he like basically
Tucker Carlson's trying to get him in
this [ __ ] position where he's
anti-democrat and anti-union he's like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about man
like and Tucker Carlos is like yeah
Union's good but Union's bad like a
[ __ ] idiot and and Chris Smalls Just
hands his hands Tucker his ass on this a
vote conservative yes I would do well
you know this is this is uh this is very
uh appropriate for the video that we
showed earlier right it's all tied
together well I mean I mean because
manga isn't conservative it's not I wish
people would stop saying that
conservative isn't fascist like they
don't want to conserve anything they
want to they want to undo what we have
to conserve uh uh looks like Oath
Keepers is trending let's see what this
is is there oath keeper news is there
something uh oh look who it is our bad
boy
uh Ryan Reilly is reporting here from
the NBC News it looks like an admitted
seditious conspiracy told the federal
judge today that he witnessed uh Oath
Keepers founder Stuart Rhodes talked to
a trump intermediary on the evening of
January 6 but didn't successfully
connect to Trump now you know we you
know we and then the audience knows
we've had Dakota Adams uh Stuart Rhodes
this guy here in the eye patch
um not to be confused with with uh
the the pirate the pirate
anyways uh Dakota Adams is a strange son
and we also had Josh Adams as a strange
wife um on the show um but Dakota has
broken down the qrf for us and for all
those folks that don't know the qrf is a
stockpile weapons that they were
stashing in a hotel room across the
Potomac waiting waiting for maybe one of
these guys to give an order to bring
those weapons across the Potomac because
as We Know
it is illegal to have a stash of weapons
like that in Washington DC so they
stored it in the state of Virginia which
is just across the water the Potomac and
Stewart Rhodes apparently had the
he actually had the the the orders he
was able to give the orders for this qrf
or the stockpile of firearms and weapons
that they would have brought across the
water and it sounds like to me in this
admission
that Stuart Rhodes was waiting for an
intermediary Roger Stone
um he was waiting for an intermediary
word from an intermediary between him
and trump it sounds like that's a
reporting doesn't it to you Gabe yeah
that's what we've uh from what we've
gathered based on the reports and the
court documents that it would seem that
there was you know someone was talking
to someone was getting back to Stuart
like there's there's a level of
separation between all these people via
burner phones right and they and they
were waiting they were waiting waiting
well they were using what's the app
Roger Stone signal is that what it is
yeah yeah that's the one where it's
private uh messaging yeah that's the
thing that Elon Musk wants to integrate
into Twitter and everyone's like uh you
can go [ __ ] yourself if you're trying to
make a second Insurrection via Twitter
right uh Christina says uh saw you all
on John's show I absolutely love your
show and Gabe couldn't be cuter if he
tried oh my God hey you got a fan whoo
baby
happy Cinco de Mayo yes
well thank you so much yes yeah and we
were on stuttering John's uh show we
went we went and reviewed his uh
Washington DC I walked in I did not know
what I was walking into but it was it
was a fun it was a funny show yeah yeah
John John and John had messaged me and
said hey can you come on the show and
I'm like yeah me and Gabe will come talk
to you and he's like great
um and he didn't tell me why it was
great but oh boy you should go check out
that episode if you go to our YouTube
channel uh And subscribe to our YouTube
channel down at the bottom on the on a
playlist down at the bottom we have my
appearances on other shows and games
appearances on those shows that video is
there where we are reviewing and I think
it's the most recent video on each
playlist uh we are reviewing uh
stuttering johns with him uh going over
his
uh failed failed attempt to hire a
videographer it is hilarious it is
hilarious
um the the if just the content that we
created that they said so thank you
Christina for for watching us on John
show and thank you for joining us here
and continue to watching our show
um so let's go down and let's see if
there's
uh Kyle Griffin see what he has to say a
North Carolina member of The Oath
Keepers has pled guilty to seditious
conspiracy
and obstruction in connection with the
January 6th attack now this is all what
I've been saying for months Gabe you've
heard me say it over and over and over
again that um the decision that was
handed down by judge Carter out in
California
with the Eastman memos and the the
communications between Trump and Eastman
on Eastman's College account it was he
worked for the college it was a college
email account they were claiming
attorney-client privilege and the judge
clearly states in that decision this is
not attorney-client privilege because
you broke the law that's what makes it
not attorney client privilege and oh by
the way the actual charge and the actual
crime that it seems to be committing is
obstruction
of an official proceeding and a
conspiracy at that so this seems really
convenient Gabe that we're getting
closer and closer with this with this
word of this North Carolina man
apparently his name is William William
Todd Wilson that's whoosh William Todd
Wilson
just call him whoosh
is the third oath keeper to admit to
seditious conspiracy um that is really
important there he has agreed to
cooperate in ongoing investigation now
again The Oath Keepers is very critical
in the the day of the January 6 in the
conspiracy of sedition and also the
obstruction of official proceeding and
the reason why is because we remember
Gabe you found the video for us and we
tried it here on the show of Enrique
tario the proud boy leader and the
founder of the oath keeper Stuart Rhodes
meeting the night before in a parking
garage yeah to plan for the next day of
January 6th and somehow some way
The Oath Keepers changed our chain that
Roger Stone's bodyguard and protection
that Jay changed from the proud boys
which was traditional for Roger Stone to
the oath keeper who has also pled guilty
to conspiracy of sedition now he was
standing next to Roger Stone the whole
day and here we start to see start to
get a whiff in this story
that Stuart Rhodes who had had
Communications with his Lieutenant who
was standing next to Roger Stone would
were was waiting for an inner Stuart
Rhodes the reporting is now and he was
waiting out of court documents and he
was waiting
for an intermediary to tell him
what to proceed with and he was waiting
for Trump's word from that intermediary
uh Ryan also has another report here big
news in the January 6 investigation Oath
Keepers a whoosh William Todd Wilson
says he was in a suit
excuse me suite at the Phoenix Park
Hotel with Stewart Rhodes on January 6th
is this the hotel that the qrf was in
Gabe potentially I don't hear I'll look
it up okay uh he was in uh Phoenix Park
Hotel with Stewart Rhodes on January 6th
with when roads put an unidentified
Trump intermediary again in the court
documents it seems to be either
unidentified maybe it's like person RS
right I don't know just initials were
you know smadger Roan I don't know
that's modular maybe we could say an
unidentified Trump intermediary on
speakerphone which really that even
makes me more suspicious that it's that
it's someone that could possibly main
name like Roger Roan
um and successfully tried to talk
unsuccessfully tried to talk to Trump so
Trump wouldn't take Don Junior's phone
calls and apparently wouldn't take the
intermediary which we're going to call
from now for right now we're gonna call
her call him Shrader Roan Roger it would
be Roger
yeah so we'll call the intermediary
Stroger Roan from now for right now
until so I looked up the Phoenix Park
Hotel it's it is not a cross but it
actually is down the way from the
capital
um so it's so it's close to the capital
yeah I can uh for for viewers if you
want to see where it is
okay I gave you the link oh this is the
Google The Google
um map they're also saying that there's
some news out of uh Louisiana for an
abortion uh bill um there's someone sent
me a link let me let me uh pull this up
first so people can see where this hotel
is at well maybe I don't know we might
be able to
um
copy there we go paste paste that some
[ __ ]
Okay so
okay let's pull this up here so we can
see this
so yeah I got the hotel that's uh North
and you go down through the park you're
right into the Capitol and so you can
see the capital down here and then the
hotel is right here marked by this pen
so it's not too far away you have the
lower Senate Park in between uh the
capital there which is the Phoenix Park
Hotel and the United States capital so
it looks like it looks like they would
um
um they weren't they weren't at least
they weren't staying across the Potomac
and they were making phone calls uh
inside Washington DC which may hurt them
even more Gabe with this federal case
right um it's possible you know I don't
know
um some of that let's see if we can find
this link of people saying uh apparently
there's some breaking news out of
Louisiana yeah Louisiana while you're
looking at that Robin says it's hb813
um to make abortion a crime of homicide
Louisiana regardless of U.S Supreme
Court decision being debated now in the
house criminal justice uh so we know
they're gonna try to overturn Roe v Wade
um which is an awful [ __ ] decision
um but here we have the states because I
think there's 13 I posted a thread early
from Irish girl
um uh She lays out the states that
actually have trigger laws
um and if you go look at that thread uh
and I'll I'll bring it back up and I'll
show you guys what the thread is you can
go read that thread you know we don't
get into the stats and stuff here much
but you can go read that thread it's
very very interesting on the states that
actually have the trigger laws but here
Greg hilborn Hilburn of let's see where
where is he USA Today which is not
exciting but you know that is what it is
hb813 uh by McCormick for La this seems
like a Louisiana house district one
founder of operation golden area oh it's
already this sorry believer in Christ
husband dad Granddad you know what's
funny is they're always like oh you you
with your pronouns you with your [ __ ]
you're a believer in Christ and your
husband dad Granddad [ __ ] yeah the the
funny thing and also like oh my God guys
we really need to fund public education
right uh because people are like oh
pronouns and it's like so they they're
like if you're a third party and you
don't know like oh who's who's if you're
trying to like oh this wallet must be
someone's like I hope they come get it
right right this is their property don't
don't like right Dad Gabe don't I guess
don't don't try to push your woke
English
appropriate language on us would you
stop that your proper grammar and [ __ ]
um everyone knows that I have horrible
grammar if you watch the show you know
it's probably cringe-worthy sometimes
all the time okay um let's let's read
this tweet here because I think this is
important breaking news to make abortion
a crime of homicide in Louisiana
regardless of the U.S Supreme Court
decision being debated now in house
criminal justice in the Louisiana
legislator so it looks like what they
want to do
is they want to make abortion a crime of
a homicide now I want to play you a
video game of one of the Republican
Party leaders the America first uh party
leaders here and listen to what listen
to what this [ __ ] [ __ ] box is
about what he thinks the doctor and
specifically the women
you know Nick Fuentes is Gabe oh yeah he
gives us Hispanics a bad name yeah I'm
gonna I'm gonna play this video over and
over and over on this show because I
think everyone should know that this is
the guy who Madison cawthorne loves this
is the guy who Marjorie Taylor green
goes to his Nazi rallies and can't
recall that she's that she spoke to him
or knows him
um this is a guy that Matt gatz likes
Paul gozar Andy Biggs all the [ __ ]
all the [ __ ] insurrectionists that we
have uh Donald Trump probably even likes
this [ __ ] and let me tell you
something else about this Nick Fuentes
he is a huge huge cow Rittenhouse fan I
mean huge and a huge coward and yeah
Hitler Hitler yeah I was gonna say
Margaret Taylor green but you know that
works too right well you know one kind
of you know one is yeah yeah
one is like the other uh okay so let's
listen let's listen to what Nick Fuentes
says about jailing women for abortions
how long he thinks they should be in
jail this is this is the Republican
Party message leader folks the woman
should be put in jail too they should
all go to jail a hundred years for the
doctor a thousand years for the woman
that's what I say let's listen to that
again in jail too they should all go to
jail a hundred years for the doctor a
thousand years for the woman that's what
I say let's listen to it one more time
just so it sinks in they should all go
to jail a hundred years the doctor a
thousand years for the woman that's what
I say oh Tony Nick Fuentes isn't their
party leader no way they would never
criminalize they would never make it
homicide they would never jail a woman
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
what can you tell me again what does the
AF stand for in the America First wait
sorry say that again Nazis they're ninja
poop Nazis they're not got it okay yeah
I just want to make sure that that was
the same American first party that you
know Matt Gates Margie Taylor green Paul
Go sir like you mentioned right that was
not good
the same one that margin Heather green
went to go speak at right and then that
denied ever knowing anything about Nick
Fuentes right
right is that that's the same America
First the exact same one the exact same
nincompoop Nazis uh Robin says
apparently it passed yesterday now Robin
uh don't get your uh feathers too much
in a tizzy here because in state
legislators and I believe Louisiana is
like this where they have two bodies
they have a governor um there are some
backstops to this
um they can also challenge this um in
court you know and I'm sure it will be
challenged almost immediately
um which I mean that's kind of the point
here of tearing down Roe v Wade is that
these protections will not be afforded
on a federal level States rats States
rats to oppress your rats yeah we want
this we want the rat to oppress your
ride so let me say it again it says it
in the [ __ ] intro
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
[ __ ] eating [ __ ] that's it that's that
is the quote okay let's go back um if
you guys have some breaking news uh like
Robin did there don't be afraid to tag
us if you can
um we would love to bring it in the show
if we can do that or try to get to it
the next day but this news is fast
moving and we got a lot of Hump dump
videos to get through holy [ __ ]
um looks like Lindsey Graham is trending
um
it's because the Madison cawthorne video
a lot of people are like no it looks
like he was questioning Chris Smalls
here
maybe I saw him I mean also also yeah
yeah I saw him earlier trending because
people were like oh this video leaked
like what made uh what type of video
made Lindsey Graham change his opinion
of Donald Trump from 2016 to 2020. right
right
um this was an hour ago here is here is
Bernie Sanders uh it looks like tossing
it to Lindsey Graham
um on this
um looks like this hearing that Chris
Smalls is in where he's talking about
Amazon being unionized let's listen in
Senator Grimm get one way you shouldn't
hold people accountable is have a
hearing where you make accusations
there's a legal system you reach
conclusions and you want a result that I
think would do a lot of damage to the
country that's what's radical here is
we've taken a single company you brought
people making accusations there's a
legal system in this country to complain
about unfair labor practices but what
you've done here today is you've tried
and convicted Amazon
uh that's that's that's that's what
that's what the accountability of
Congress is for that's what we the
people get to vote in that's why we have
Congress you dumb [ __ ] that's
why we have the Senate is so you
[ __ ] can hold them accountable
even if the [ __ ] Criminal Courts
won't or the [ __ ] civil courts won't
that to expose and to hold Private
Industry accountable in this country
where they need to be elegantable it's
really [ __ ] bone-headed of course
it's not surprising coming from Lindsey
Graham
um and again I don't know if he's the
the tea bagger or being tea bagged but
here but you know uh since we got
oh my God okay this [ __ ] doesn't stop
hitting the fan it doesn't and we tried
it okay on this show for two hours we
try to keep you updated
and we try to we try to stay afloat as
much as we can right um a tea bag is
Treading Water baby
[Laughter]
so so uh uh there's uh some other stuff
trending here oh [ __ ]
um looks like I'm of course I make
America great again is trending Epcot is
trending uh but let's go back to the the
top the top list here and see if we've
got anything else we've got we're 53
minutes into the second hour holy [ __ ]
that was a fast two hours Gabe yeah this
is the fast two hours this goes by wow
this goes by so quick maybe 12 hours is
totally okay all right well when you
talk about teabagging someone for 45
minutes it goes fast I don't know yeah I
mean people are okay watching us eat I
guess they also could be like I don't
know it's like I could eat I could have
tacos every day so if you know we need a
30 minute segment we're just me
reviewing tacos again I totally will do
it
let's see here Kevin Kramer is training
Chris Evans has here new uh Republican
U.S senator from North Dakota Kevin
Kramer says the fetus is worth losing
the mother's life says there's oh Jesus
[ __ ]
so apparently Kevin Kramer
um gives Chris credit here since I read
his tweet uh let me see I want to move
down here though pretty fast because
we're running out of time and I'll see
if we can find video this is their video
of this or is this just in a [ __ ]
text
I don't know holy [ __ ] [ __ ] is he
tweeting this [ __ ] oh my God that that
okay so this is again I want I'm gonna
go back to
everyone I want to do again here's what
I'm gonna do again I want you to listen
to this again this is very [ __ ]
important
um apparently this senator from wherever
the [ __ ] he's from wherever
the [ __ ] he's from is listening to this
guy let's listen in
the woman should be put in jail too they
should all go to jail a hundred years
for the doctor a thousand years for the
woman that's what I say and also if they
if they if you know if they're gonna die
[ __ ] them [ __ ] them you know they're
like they're like pro-life people really
do really do stop when it comes to the
mother's life don't you don't isn't that
funny I just want to say one thing about
the woman's life everyone out there for
the difference get the [ __ ] out of here
you pieces of [ __ ] [ __ ] who is this
guy go ahead Gabe oh I just want to say
this [ __ ] [ __ ] Nick Fuentes yep
that's my message uh that's my message
for today who's this Senator what's his
name Kevin Kramer Kevin Kramer with a c
um North Dakota North Dakota member of
the United States Senate yeah and we
don't we don't normally hear from this
guy probably because he keeps his
[ __ ] traps shut but he couldn't keep
his trap shut on and it's a good thing
folks
we do not want them to shut up we want
them to tell us our views that way you
have the appropriate information to go
out and electioneer against these
[ __ ] because it is up to us to
make sure that there are no Madison
cawthorns there are no Nick Fuentes
there are no Marjorie Taylor greens
Lauren boberts Kevin McCarthy's Mitch
McConnell's and this [ __ ] [ __ ] box
Kevin Kramer who I've never heard of in
my life I've never heard of Kevin Greene
in my [ __ ] life
well going through his Twitter feed I
see a lot of hypocrisy let's appreciate
teachers when Republicans actually want
to restrict funding well they don't want
public information right right
you know oh hey we can solve this we can
solve this issue by a National Day of
Prayer what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] so
did he did he tweet this [ __ ] did he
tweet this [ __ ] is that what
uh his life is [ __ ] worthless and I'm
pro-life but I hate the [ __ ] woman so
[ __ ] her and [ __ ] I mean no I'm not
seeing anything where he explicitly says
that [ __ ] people I'm seeing a lot of
stuff about like national resources and
Hey Kevin Kramer you got an open
invitation to come on this show and I
will [ __ ] eat your lunch you son of a
[ __ ] this is [ __ ] ridiculous and
this is why this is why it is so [ __ ]
important for you to get your messaging
out there and Gabe just alluded to it
with this guy's Twitter feed guys you
can start the conversation with anyone
in your community in your PTA in your
church at the [ __ ] grocery store you
can say this one question will get you
started on a conversation trust me it'll
get you started this question did you
hear Republicans in Florida are trying
to ban math that is the [ __ ] one
question you can start this whole
goddamn conversation out with did you
hear in Florida Republicans are trying
to ban math
because well I don't I don't have I
don't have uh the current video but I do
have something from 2017. are you saying
that he he just didn't come up with this
idea that this old wrinkly white ball
sack from North Dakota this Kevin Kramer
has helped his idea for years huh that's
[ __ ] ah but boy I couldn't [ __ ]
imagine this one was about women's
suffrage
so we'll take a listen to what he says
oh baby this this should be [ __ ]
enlightening as hell
um
oh my God
okay we're gonna we're uh we're we're
gonna go over on this but we're gonna
play this video here I want to hear what
he's I want to hear what this [ __ ]
bonehead says
about women the point of my statement
was
these women who put on these
um white pantsuits to quote celebrate
suffrage we're really there to be rude
to Donald Trump that was obvious not
just nothing
ah they were error protesting down from
that's so horrible oh my God he's like
unless you're wearing a white Hood oh my
my God what a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ] for
every for these guys to be so concerned
about someone else's [ __ ] they sure are
[ __ ] a bunch of goddamn [ __ ] let's
listen in but in addition to their
clothing that their gestures or hand
gestures or thumbs down their quick exit
from the oh my God thumbs down the
gallery ahead of the president they look
silly they look they were being rude
it's part of their ongoing
oh it's part of their ongoing protest I
don't want in a protest we should cancel
these women in white pants they're
really offending us with their thumbs
down oh my god oh what if our feelings
are hurt what are we gonna do pants
Jesus Christ pants get white pants white
suits if you can hear my voice out there
this is what we're up against it really
if we get a message and we build a
coalition of everyone who is around the
same [ __ ] issue to to defeat fascism
which is it which is fascism in this
country is a Maga ahead is [ __ ]
trumpism with a Maga head on this
[ __ ] fascism in this country if
you're willing if you want to defeat it
and you want pro-democracy here these
people are going to be easy to be but we
have to do it together we have to do it
together the only way to defeat these
[ __ ] fascists and these crybaby
nincompoop Nazis Jesus Christ Hitler
Hitler would be so disappointed Gabe in
this [ __ ] he would be so
disappointed he's crying that they were
given thumbs down Jesus Christ what a
bunch of wimps
um
was designed to be a protest not to be a
celebration of suffrage and to the
degree it was a celebration of suffrage
what the [ __ ] do you think suffrage was
dumb [ __ ]
oh the actual [ __ ] he actually believes
that women's suffrage wasn't a protest
what does he think women's suffrage was
but also protest I believe that's uh
which amendment which amendment which
amendment they would like to take that
away from you too Gabe right they would
like to especially women and everyone
doubts me that they're going to come
from the Constitutional Amendment that
women's suffrage gave us which was the
19th Amendment in 1919 to 1920 when it
was ratified no they're not going to
come for the vote bull [ __ ] [ __ ] they
won't the hell they won't come from a
woman's vote this is clear right here in
this video
it's kind of like I think further
expression of the problem with
Democratic politics in America today and
that is it's all about division it's all
about identity politics and it's time to
get over all of that here's the thing
folks and I'm going to tell you this and
and I agree with this guy right here we
should be divisive we should not allow
fascists to take our country we should
divide them we should divide them among
ourselves we should divide them among
each other and let them fight it out and
pro-democracy win because fascist if we
don't be divisive towards these
[ __ ] if we are not getting our
message straight and we aren't we aren't
doing our job to fight for democracy
they will win it will happen it will
happen let's listen well and uh they're
members of Congress after all so
um I don't buy the I don't buy their
argument uh that it was a celebration of
suffrage I think that they should be
celebrating the fact that they're women
members of Congress sitting in the joint
session listening to the president of
the United States on equal 40 minutes
and uh sort of get over the you know
this come on a bunch I again I can't
even I can't even give him Jesus Christ
well this this is why this bonehead is
is [ __ ] trending maybe he'll make it
to bonehead of the week I don't know
there's probably a lot of other
boneheads right oh yeah I've got a list
of boneheads already right well go to go
to Twitter and follow us at Tony
Michaels pod4 the bone end of the week
poll uh also subscribe to the YouTube
channel because this week is the first
week that the bone and the weep hole
will be on YouTube I'm sure you'll
figure that out right we'll figure out
how to do that okay all right okay I'll
figure it out I'm competent enough I
went to school I got an education
despite using public you were you were
able to put Madison Gotham over his his
butt mullet so right I audience be fully
confident that Gabe will get it up there
and make sure to download
um this episode including all the others
on Apple Spotify and Google go follow us
over there give us a five star review
why you're there uh like us on Facebook
as well because we stream every single
day every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central nine
Pacific from you YouTube Twitter twitch
find us there and if you're on Facebook
we also are on the books of face on
Midas Touch Facebook page we simulcast
from Midas Touch Facebook page the link
is right there if you want to if you
want to click on to go to YouTube to to
take the bone end of the week poll don't
forget to click on that link to
subscribe so you can get the bone in the
week Bowl now on YouTube and Twitter for
bone end of the week tomorrow in the
second hour we will go through bone in
the week until we start the show
tomorrow at noon Eastern serves up
[ __ ] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries
I think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow
toning on social media at the Tony
Michaels and until next time raise a
fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
Murphy's newborn headass Beacon